what I'm here to show you um there are a
lot of other really great talks going on
right now so in the interest of helping
you make a fully informed decision about
where you want to go although it's
you're kind of stuck here now uh I want
to start by telling you kind of what I
aim to get across during this talk uh in
the next hopefully less than 20 minutes
um and my goal is to show you that the
shiny UI editor is ready to be used um
in the real world and not just toy
scenarios um and I'm going to do this by
walking you through building a shiny app
from scratch uh using the UI
editor so first I want to start with a
little bit of context uh which is around
10 years ago I remember building my
first shiny app um and I remember I
opened up our studio and I clicked new
app and there was the Geer template and
then I took my code and I shoved it in
there and then I never touched the UI
again because it was terrifying
and I could barely get my code in there
I'm not going to mess with the UI um and
then you know even eight or so years
later after I had done enough shiny and
web development to actually get a job on
the shiny team I still found myself like
dreading that initial prototype period
where you you have a cool API you want
to play with um and you have to set up
the UI you have to you know make things
go where you want and that was it's just
kind of annoying and sometimes you just
want to get that done really quickly um
and so these two scenarios
really motivated uh the development of
the UI editor um and I think they could
be summed up in kind of a general like
mission statement um because all great
things such as posit have a mission
statement um and in researching how to
give good talks one of the things that I
always saw was you should read directly
from the slides um so I'm going to do
that here to read this mission statement
so the mission of the shiny UI editor is
to help users turn their data analyses
into interactive shiny dashboards you we
want to generate app code that can be
later modified with or without the
editor um and this is for both those new
to shiny and also experts who want to
expedite their development process okay
so now we have context we can start but
just actually one more context slide um
which is it's great to have a mission
statement and talk about all that stuff
but really what is the UI editor maybe
you don't know what it is we haven't
talked about it a ton um so first and
foremost the UI editor is a drag and
drop visual editor for shiny
applications uis and it's focusing
specifically on the UI it's a shiny UI
editor or does it actually uh we'll
we'll get into that in a little bit um
you can get the UI editor via an r
package um or if you're one of those
crazy people that likes to use VSS code
to write R we have a vs code extension
uh you can be one of the single of
people that have ever used
it okay so now we can actually get
started with the demo so say you just
going to pick a random profession or a
data scientist um and you've built an
awesome Cordo
document so the Cordo document pulls
some air quality data from the EPA um we
have this little blackbox function
called query data you don't need to
worry about that but basically you can
pull location uh and then various
pollutants that go with that location
and in your quarto do you have a plot
you have some statistics that you pull
out of that data and you have a table um
the problem is that this is static right
now it's hard-coded for Chicago maybe
you want to look at someplace else um so
this seems like a good situation for an
interactive shiny app but how do we
actually get started with that you know
it's nice to say like use the UI editor
but how do you actually do that um and
so assuming you have the package
installed I want to talk about one of
the newer ways to do that which is with
an addin that we have
so say you're here uh you have our
studio open uh it's a project it's where
your quarter document is you can just go
now into the add-ins Pane and you find
the one that says run shiny UI editor
you click that and it will pop up the UI
editor uh to this little template
Chooser
interface so from there um you can
choose a template so in this case we're
going to choose this grid geyser
template you select it and then you
scroll down you click next um and it
will now open up uh that template it's
written that to your uh local file
system it's started running a preview
and everything looks pretty good you can
get ready to go okay but maybe you don't
actually like that template maybe that's
you know we we only have one plot and
one table um so maybe this one isn't
what we want you can use uh the back
button or the undo button go back and
say you know what I want this other
template um and that's kind of to show
that like anywhere in the UI editor you
make a mistake you don't want to do
something you can go back um now we're
in this new template that we've chosen
you can use the app preview which is
always there uh to check to see if the
app that you are working with looks
right okay so now that we have a
template open everything's good we can
move on to actually updating the apps
layout um there's nothing like new here
this is what I talked about in last
year's uh conference talk and so in the
interest of I set out this goal of like
I'm going to take you from beginning to
end of a project um I'm not going to
hide anything which means that I'm going
to go really fast through this um so if
you get lost there 's lots of
documentation online that you can use um
but really the point is not to show you
how to like there's a lot better ways to
learn how to do something I just want to
show that you can do something with the
UI
editor so now that we're in the app uh
we probably want to update the app title
and so we can do this uh just by
clicking the title right now it says
chick weits uh and then we go into the
properties pane on the right um we can
update the properties in this case we're
going to call it air quality makes sense
uh and then we can left align it um and
so that's basically how you just update
you know any given node in the uui
editor so one thing also you might
notice is that this template that we've
chosen has two plots we only want one
plot um and we can fix this just by
selecting it and just picking this big
red delete button and it now ceases to
exist so any node you can edit you can
delete um but then now the app looks a
little bit Barren on the bottom and we
need a table so we can do this um by
going to the left which is the elements
pet finding a table output and just
dragging it onto our app It'll ask us a
couple questions about what we want to
name where we put it call it table very
creatively um and now we have a table in
our
app well the table is there um you know
that's there's still a big Chasm there
and we want to put some statistics in
and so we're going to use um some value
boxes like the ones that Carson showed
uh we want two of them and so we can do
that uh using the layout features of the
UI editor by adding another row can make
our table bigger to fit in there and
then we can just drag on some more value
boxes fill out information about them
check uh in the app preview see things
maybe need a little bit of tweaking this
is a common pattern of you know you go
to the preview and then rearrange things
uh to see uh what looks best so we made
the plot a little bit wider the table a
little bit wider things are starting to
look pretty good um so now we also we
have the places for where all of our
output sits but we don't actually have
any inputs and what's the point of
making a shiny app if we don't have any
Dynamic inputs um so we can do that uh
just delete the old inputs that came
with a template uh drag in uh an input
to set the city so it's going to be a
radio button uh we can go set you know
the input ID and set the options and
then we can also drag in uh an input for
the pollutants which is going to be a
checkbox um and I don't know if you're
like me um but I can never ever remember
the Syntax for things like checkbox
options um but the UI editor has nice
features uh where it you know you don't
have to remember this in text you just
have to fill in the input um which is
pretty nice another one that it has for
that is in value boxes you have this
nice little icon it uses this BS icon
package but there's 1,800 icons in that
and I certainly don't remember all of
those um and so we have a little input
that allows you to search through all of
those and see previews of what they look
like um which which makes your life a
lot nicer and that's something that you
know even if you're an advanced China
user having that feature uh can be nice
um so there's just you know lots of
little things uh with the UI editor that
can make your life
easier okay so the app now looks
basically like what we want it to but
how do we make it behave like what we
want to it's all great that we have
plots and tables but if they're not
actually hooked up to anything that's
not great so this is some of the kind of
new stuff uh that's come to the UI
editor recently and I'm excited uh to
show it off
so the um we have this plot PL output
right uh and the plot output was in the
template so it has some output code
associated with it and if we want to go
fill that in with our output code we
click on it and there's a new button
that pops up that says show in server
you click that and we go back to our
studio and we see that it's highlighted
the output code for that plot so now all
we have to do is go back to our Cordo
document where we made that plot
originally copy and paste that code into
that output that it highlighted for us
save the app then we can go back to the
UI editor um and then open up the
preview and we can see the plot has now
updated to be what it was in the Cordo
do so from that uh you know we're kind
of making that process of going back and
forth a little bit
smoother um but sometimes we don't have
output codes so in the case of this
table we added that and so there is no
output code so you don't know what you
need to copy and paste uh in this case
there's another button that shows up
called generate server code generate
server code will put in like a basic
template for you based on the output
type um and then you can view that just
like we did before so now it's inserted
a rendered GT function it's just showing
the iris data set right now but we can
do the same thing we did before now copy
and paste the code from the Cordo
document this is actually real speed
this is how fast I uh work on my
computer um and then once again we're
going to do this for the value boxes
there's a text output there uh just go
nice and
quick so that's how we can kind of go
from our outputs um and get our server
code hooked up so now we can see our
value box uh is producing uh statistic
that we had made in our quara document
so you know it's all well and good that
output bindings work um but there's
another type of binding which is an
input binding the editor knows a little
bit about them as well not quite as much
because they're a little bit more uh
there's not as much to do with them um
but before I get into that I want to do
an interlude which is not really a shiny
UI editor thing but more of a uh a uh
just a shiny development best practice
which is we're going to take uh this air
quality data that we've been working and
put it in a reactive variable um and I'm
doing this and I'm saying it's a best
practice but really I'm doing it so that
when I do the input stuff I only have to
put it in one place um so right now uh
the query data function gets called once
in this reactive and we use that in our
plot and our table so this is not
necessary but if you want to make
performance shiny apps you should you
should probably do
this okay so we have those inputs uh how
do we actually hook them up we can just
copy the input ID that we have go back
to our server code find that reactive
variable right now we've hardcoded ch
we can replace that hard-coded city data
with just input then dollar sign if I
could ever type city um which is the
input name then we can save that once
again this is a theme go back open up
the preview we can toggle and see yep
now that input is hooked up so we can
slowly start building up our app using
the UI editor without actually closing
it so we're going to repeat that same
thing for pollutants uh once again at
real
speed and we can see now everything is
hooked up so our inputs are now hooked
up uh to the output um so the app is
actually you know kind of functioning
like a interactive shiny
app so say you're you've done this and
you're happy one thing you might be
wondering uh is like am I trapped in the
UI editor forever how do I stop um
luckily you can just close the window
press the big X and then that shuts down
the UI editor and because the UI editor
is always saving your code every change
you make that doesn't matter you can
just shut it down whenever and it's
going to always look like what it
does okay so quickly uh this is what our
app looks like now uh that it's current
like after we've done all we've done
this is what the app looks like if you
just run it um it's not going to win any
Design Awards um but it you know it does
some stuff uh but uh one of the things
that we might notice is like you know we
develop this quarter document we know
all about this API but if we give this
to somebody they're not going to know
what to do with it like what what is
City what is pollutants I don't know
anything about that so we should
probably add some pros to explain what's
going on so people can actually you know
use our app other than
us okay so now we need to go back into
the UI Editor to work on that so how do
we actually do that um like I said
before it's actually fairly simple all
we need to do is in the same thing where
we were before run the UI editor addin
again and it pops up and the UI editor
is there and that's because the code is
the source of Truth um so you can shut
it down and restart it at any point and
it will look exactly like it did um so
now we're back into the UI editor uh
editing the exact app that we've been
creating
so now that the editor is actually
running we can do uh we can add a new uh
text input that we or text output I
guess that we've uh built that I'm
excited about which is markdown text and
so you can just drag it like you do any
other input and then it gives you this
nice big text box on the right and you
can fill that text box in with whatever
you want using markdown syntax you know
you can make it italics you can make it
bold if you made the Cordo document uh
in the beginning you know how to use
markdown um and so we're going to do
that to write a description of what the
city input is and what the pollutant
input is and so now it looks good people
understand but they're scrolling that's
not great so one more quick tweak of the
app we're going to close it rearrange
stuff um and now the app is looking you
know pretty good like I said not going
to win any Design Awards but it's
certainly functional um and something
that we can give users to work with
especially if you're trying to deliver
quickly um rapidly prototype this is a
good way to do that I did this in you
know in real time in about about 15
minutes so so that was a just a
whirlwind tour like I said if you didn't
follow all that don't worry um that
really wasn't meant to be a how-to it's
meant to be a what you can do um but to
recap kind of where we are with the UI
editor um which is basically after a
year of we've had this nice big scary
Alpha tag on the website um saying like
use at your own Peril your computer
might explode there are only like three
or four Compu computers that exploded
though so wasn't too bad we're pretty
happy uh to say uh that we want to take
it out of alpha we want to say you know
people should come and start using this
um and you know the water's fine come on
in um there will I'm sure there there's
still bugs um so if you find them please
report them or if you have features that
you want please uh put those on the
GitHub page there'll be links in the at
the end um and we're going to do kind of
more of a formal announcement soon you
know like before mile blog post and some
uh some documentation updates um but
you're you're the first to know uh that
we've taken off an arbitrary label of
don't use this and said now you can use
it so that's where we are um but where
are we going um and so there's a lot of
ways that we can go um from here but one
of the things that I'm really excited
about that we're going to start pushing
on is more intelligent server actions
you saw like you know now you can select
uh server code that exists but you know
there's some things that we could do to
make that process a little bit more
elegant uh more seamless uh so we're
really excited to work on that also uh a
python version for pie shiny um and if
you're one of the crazy people that
wants to use the vs code extension uh it
actually does exist already we there is
a python version of the UI editor it
just doesn't do much there's not that
many uh elements you're not going to be
making a particularly interesting app um
but if for some reason you want to try
it good luck um so but that's going to
certainly be iterated on a lot more in
the future um cuz hopefully we can uh
make it easy to make pie shiny apps the
same
way okay so I jammed a lot into a pretty
short talk um so I encourage you to
visit the website uh it has links to the
GitHub and all sorts of stuff um you
know tutorials on getting started and
and specific tasks so um these are my
social handles uh if you want to follow
me ask me questions there also github's
a great place to do it it um so thank
you so
[Applause]
much thank you Nick so um we have time
for a question okay you were so fast
there is time um and the question I'm
going to ask is um can you use this
shiny toy that is coming out of the Toy
face um with apps not created with it
okay so in theory yes because the code
is the source of truth that being said
you would have had to have built your
app in one of two ways you could use the
new BS lib navbar page or page navbar uh
or use the grid layout grid page so you
know there's that's a limited subset of
apps um as we develop it more we're
going to add more and more um you know
Bas level things and then hopefully the
idea you know the like we've made it
phase of the UI editor would be
basically any shiny app you can load it
up and it will let you let you edit it
but right now yes with the asterisk of
you better have written it in this very
specific set of ways that we have
programmed for okay thank
you